our man Emmanuel Schaefer says when
Toyota brought out the first generation
rav4 1994 it basically launched the
crossover SUV segment as we know it
today rave incidentally stands for
recreational activity vehicle customers
buying the rave for can now choose
between a hybrid or non hybrid version
the option of an additional electric
motor is part of the new overhaul the
Toyota rav4 has undergone a facelift
quite literally the front now looks very
different the nose has been reshaped and
the front grille slimmed down for a look
that is altogether more sleek
the refor utilizes Toyota's Hybrid
Synergy Drive that powers the Prius and
other semi electric models and the
brands lineup and comes with a 2.5 liter
normally aspirated gasoline engine
assisted by an electric motor now tried
and tested technology at Toyota amanwe
says the addition of Toyotas hybrid
drive is probably the most important
update in the new generation rave 4 you
can choose between options either front
drive where the electric motor is
installed at the front as with a normal
gasoline engine or all-wheel drive where
the electric motor is fitted in the rear
driving the rear axle and doing away
with the transfer case and card on shaft
the all-wheel drive version costs an
extra three thousand euros one thing
this Toyota isn't is speedy 180 km/h is
the top speed another chance to save
fuel and reduce your co2 emissions which
is probably more important for customers
who care about the environment and not
for a hybrid
Emanuel says the 2.5 liter gasoline
engine and electric motor produce a
combined output of 145 kilowatts or 197
horsepower the car takes just over eight
seconds to reach 100 km/h
that's quite respectable considering it
weighs at least 1700 kilos when empty
and according to the manufacturer only
uses 5 litres of fuel per 100 kilometers
in the interior toyota has added more
soft touch surfaces the steering wheel
is new there are new onboard features
and a 7-inch screen for the multimedia
system passengers also get to enjoy the
ride the rav4 has one of the most
spacious cabins in the class
the trunk offers an impressive 547
liters of space or 501 liters in this
hybrid version the additional electric
motor also increases the overall weight
to 1.7 tonnes but those are the only
differences
there are three different drive versions
for the rave for first of all the hybrid
version that we're testing then there's
the two liter gasoline had a 2-liter
diesel engine
but anyone wanting all-wheel-drive will
have to go for the hybrid version
because unlike the previous generation
you can no longer combine the diesel
with all-wheel-drive and automatic
transmission Toyota is hoping that 60%
of customers will opt for the hybrid a
plus for the environment the manuals
take on the 4th generation of the Toyota
rav4 the overall concept makes a lot of
sense it drives well and as a hybrid is
even relatively green but he has two
small criticisms first he finds the
choice of dry version somewhat limited
and second the lack of visibility to the
rear the D pillar is very broad which
diminishes the drivers rear view on
target of in Fulani Cassandra versus
fellow